l'historienne anne marie royer pantin
connaît tout du parc floral de la source
la source c'est bien sûr celle du loiret
en fait une résurgence de la loire qui
suscita beaucoup de curiosité pour ce
lieu c'est au coeur du parc que se
trouve la remontée de l'eau c'est le
bouillon aujourd'hui il faut quand même
dire que notre bouillon n'est plus très
bouillonnant c'est une toute petite
soupe qui mijote tandis qu autrefois
surtout la découverte c'était vraiment
un jaillissement traîtres et aux
questions voire l'europe
racheté par la mairie d'orléans dans les
années 60 ce parc floral a de tout temps
symboliser une douceur de vivre
orléanaise
c'est aussi à satellite d'orléans dans
l'histoire ça l'a été puisque olives et
les bords du loir et c'était vraiment
l'art de vivre l'élégance le château la
guinguette les promenades sion en canoë
donc pour depuis toujours présents les
années c'est à c'est un lieu de douceur
de bonheur de vivre
c'est en 1967 avec l'organisation des
floralies que ce parc s'est inscrit dans
une vocation horticole et artistique
aujourd'hui il suffit d'écarter quelques
branches d'arbres avec anne-marie pour
retrouver un peu de cette gloire passée
il est arrivé là à l'occasion des
grandes floralies internationales de
1967 avec d'autres oeuvres d'art qu'on a
installé en plein air vous savez c'était
à ce moment-là un musée en plein air
extraordinaire c'est tout l'imaginaire
de la sologne qui concentre la sous les
arbres parce qu'il nous parle d'art il
nous parle aussi de littérature et de
tous et très très beau thème de la
sologne sauvage
[Musique]
anne-marie emmène le public dans ses
escapades insolite à travers des
conférences certains dimanches d'été